House Democrats say president Trump's
ordered to kill Iranian general Qasem
Soleimani was a reckless move done
without the consultation of Congress it
is unprecedented the level at which this
administration is seeking to obscure the
facts from the Congress and the American
people
Thursday's vote on the House floor is
meant to deliver a rebuke to the
president that the democratic-led
chamber has little confidence in Trump's
military decision-making toward Iran
despite his justifications we caught a
total monster and we took him out and
that should have happened a long time
ago we did it because they were looking
to blow up our embassy we also did it
for other reasons that were very obvious
somebody died one of our military people
died people were badly wounded just a
week before and we did it and we had a
shot at him and I took it and that shot
was pinpoint accurate and that was the
end of a monster the War Powers
Resolution passed in the house on
Thursday directs the President to
terminate the use of US forces in Iran
without congressional approval but how
much power this measure carries is
unclear it is a non-binding resolution
which under normal circumstances means
it does not carry the force of law but
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi says the War
Powers Act is a special circumstance
that gives the resolution legality that
it does not have to be signed by the
President of the United States the
Congress of the United States and this
full power and full voice can speak in a
United Way about what the War Powers Act
should look like and that should count
for something
House Republicans call the vote a
partisan distraction this resolution has
as much force of law as a new year's
resolution this resolution is not
safeguarding our Constitution but
attacking our Constitution by attempting
to divest a duly elected president of
his commander and chief powers a similar
resolution is pending in the US Senate
where at least two Republicans have said
they will support the measure to curb
Trump's
wrong war powers but whether the
resolutions will have that effect or
will simply be ignored by the president
is a question that may be decided in the
courts hi Joe Castro al Jazeera
Washington